THE RULES COMMITTEE --
FOR THURSDAY JANUARY TENTH
TWENTY NINETEEN IS HEREBY CALLED
ORDER --
PLEASE BE ADVISED OF THE AUDIO
AND VIDEO RECORDING OF TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS PREMADE SAUCE BEING
TELEVISED --
MANSERGH TO PEACE CALL THE ROLL
COOLEY HERE CARILLO HERE DEEP.
LARA.
GRAYSON HERE KAMLAGER-DOVE HERE
QUIRK SILVA HERE FROM MOST HERE.
REVERSED HERE WORKS HERE MATHIS
HERE -- WE
HAVE A QUORUM.
A WE HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA WHICH
TODAY INCLUDES THE APPOINTMENT
OF CON A PUSH START TO THE NEWLY.
CREATED A WORKPLACE CONDUCT
PANEL.
WHICH IS AN IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE FOR GOVERNOR SUBCOMMITTEE ON
HARASSMENT.
THE JOINT COMMITTEE.
LAST YEAR IN THE ADOPTION THE
NEW POLICY ON A JULY TWENTY
FIFTH JUNE TWENTY FIFTH --
SO IS OUR MOTION ON THE CONSENT
AGENDA SO KINDLY.
SECOND PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
COOLEY FINE COOLEY AYE.
AYE CARILLO ID. FIVE D. FIVE
FLORA AYE FLORA AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE ARTWORK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE PROMISE I
PROMISE I REQUEST.
REVERSE I WORKS.
WORKS I MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE MUCH BECAUSE SHE'S
VERY GOOD --
THAT MOTION IS PASSED --
SO AT THIS TIME WE WILL ADJOURN
THE ASSEMBLY RULES COMMITTEE.
AND THE ASSEMBLY CONTAGION OF
THE JOINT RULES COMMITTEE --
AND ALSO FOR THAT WE HAVE A
CONSENT AGENDA TODAY.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
AGENDA SOBER SECOND I THINK THE
FIVE FOUR FIVE FOUR AYE SENATE.
GRAYSON AYE KAMLAGER-DOVE YES
KAMLAGER-DOVE FIVE QUIRK SILVA
AYE BURKE VIRAL MOST I PROMISE I
READ THIS.
REVIEW WHERE I WORKS AYE MATHIS
AYE MATHIS AYE NOTHING SHE COMES
OKAY THAT MOTIONS PASSED AND THE
STAFF OF THIS COMMITTEE IS
ADJOURNED